[Music]
we're here
hey dom here we are again can i just say
i'm reluctant
to put my headphones on why because i
have deb in their hair
your hair does look good today you know
how much i like debonair hair it's not
often that i get debonair hair
it's a freakish occurrence well
you don't have to wear the headphones
the only person you'll miss
because you can hear me is john the
producer i think i will put them on
are you sure but i just want to kind of
what's the word cement just for a moment
dab in their hair can you talk about
devin her hair for a second
yeah debonair hair is something that i
don't prepare
because yeah but it's what you like to
wear it's a poem
um lots of times whatever i'll style my
hair and it'll look one way look another
i don't really
care about it one way or the other but
then
sometimes more often than not when i
wake up in the morning and i've got
crazy bed head yeah
i've slept in a weird way and we'll get
into that in a second
i'll just get water and i'll just kind
of like plaster my hair down
to make it calm down a little bit and
more often than not when i leave the
house then
there's a much higher chance that i'll
have debonair hair
which is a little bit of a pompadou yeah
it's got a it's got like a it's like a
little wave
i'm gonna ruin it now but there you go
that was debonair hair can i write a
poem about that just now yeah maybe a
song about oh it's
so much better with the cans on to hear
your voice it's called
debonair hair by dom
when i wake up without a care
put water on my head then dab debonair
hair
i walk downstairs now what should i wear
well i don't really care i've got
debonair hair
thank you very much dominic that's a
poem about your
hair you could also achieve deb in their
hair whether that's you bills
yup or you guys at home if you've got
stories about how you
accidentally have a great hairstyle let
us know
i don't think i'll get debonair here now
a bit
a bit too thin and too short my hair's
thin too
i'll say it right now and i don't i have
no shame in saying yeah
if i do get to a point where i am
noticeably
losing my hair either a massive ball
patch or crazy receding
i'm getting that hair surgery oh are you
yeah why not
i'm i'm just going to shave mine off i
mean you've had
a skin head yeah quite a few times in
your life and you can rock it so at
least you know if you get to that point
when a skinhead works for me you know
but you want to keep your dab in your
hair
i'm a bit precious with my hair you look
good though
thanks yeah oh emails and real mails
fastest tigers slow as snails should we
do some questions
why not i'm not excited about this one
because
um cara from cheshire has got in touch
with us and
uh that's where i spent a huge amount of
my
childhood stockport in cheshire oh she's
in greater manchester
um and cara this is a question for you
bills all right
cara said billy exactly how smug did you
feel about the fact that the other
hobbits had to do dialogue training
when you were just allowed to use your
natural charming
glaswegian brogue ah now here's the
thing
i i well i actually did do
um some voice stuff dialogue training
because the original idea was
we all had the sort of
accent like you ended up using kind of
west country
west country um or maybe not frodo maybe
frodo was always a little rp
yeah but um when we started messing
around with the accents
i think basically pete said you're just
not as funny
and or west country accent
so um and i i was kind of
i was i was kind of quite happy at that
because
for one thing i love to hear scottish
voices and things because i feel like we
don't hear them enough
but in the world of tolkien there is a
lot of different accents and it's lovely
but in the books it does say
that the tooks living their own country
which made me think of like scotland and
they invented
golf which sounded like scotland and
they were the heads of the clans
and the shire and it just and took
actually is an old gaelic word meaning
to bang a drum and i just like the idea
of them of the hobbits having a scottish
clan clans up there you know
and on top of that i also liked
because it was four hobbits all quite
similar that it would be nice to um
make it more obvious on which one is
which which i think is important because
we still get confused
yeah who was mary who was pippin and
then
it was nice way of kind of making pippin
a bit of an individual
yeah i mean last night in the q a that i
did someone said
will you be singing the last goodbye on
the podcast and i just wrote no that's
the other one
people still get us confused and get
billy and dom confused not just mary and
pippen
it's crazy all right we've got another
question here oh
from sarah in ann arbor
in michigan have you ever been to
michigan here we go
not only have i been in michigan i know
ann arbor
i i have family in michigan really so
when i was a young man
i used to go to michigan around ann
arbor
like um mount clemons around that area
and so in the same way that you used to
hang around
cheshire and around that area i was in
ann arbor michigan
what um what's the vibe at ann arbor
well the thing is it's it's around
detroit
so a lot of people there were working in
um
the auto industry making cars so
my my dad's sisters
both of them went to detroit with their
husbands
to work in the general motors
so they lived around that area which
meant we would go and visit them every
year
when i was sort of six seven eight
nine ten years old when back when
michigan was a thriving
growing yeah yeah and they lived in a
sort of suburbs and
that was the first time i ever saw uh
mcdonald's
and everything was very american and
there was no sidewalks because everyone
drove everywhere
so we would be walking i i remember
walking when i was like 11
years old yeah i remember walking when i
was 11 years old but not on
no sidewalk no pavement oh right and
someone shouted out a car
buy a car man what are you doing yeah
exactly
so uh i've spent a lot of time in ann
arbor
we digressed there a little bit bills
but sarah
from ann arbor in michigan asked us do
you think lord rings paid the way
paved the way for the marvel cinematic
universe intricate storytelling
fantasy elements etc would you like to
answer that
tom you're a good one for breaking down
movies and what they're all about hmm
i feel like marvel's such a massive
franchise that it was probably gonna
happen anyway
um i think lord the rings did a lot of
things
for kind of movie history
movie legacy was the first major fantasy
film that was noticed by the academy
i think there's been films over the
years that got a few maybe special
effects
nods or visual effects okay but not best
picture
a fantasy movie had never won best
picture
so i think i think that was helpful for
films like marvel to say there's there's
an audience here
but i'm not i'm not sure really
um and certainly the way that pete
shot the movie i mean i've seen pretty
much
direct takeoffs of pete shots
and other big blockbuster movies where
you're like that is completely from
lord of the rings yeah for sure i'm sure
younger filmmakers have watched it and
thought
how i do that show yeah imitations the
best form of
flattery and so on that's what they say
uh do you have a favorite marvel film
hold on hold on dom let me have a think
because
i'm getting into the very deep parts of
my brain right now to think about this
well you think i'll give you a second to
think mine's doctor strange i think
because it has
some nice elements of comedy with some
fun
psychedelia i think benedict cumberbatch
is very funny in it our friend benny
wong isn't it benny wong's and
anything with benny wong and it's worth
watching no benny he's a good man
and uh it's just a bit of a romp it's
exactly what you're looking for in a
marvel film there's adventure there's
fun there's battles there's craziness
there's colors tilda swinton is
incredible
yeah yeah my favorite actors no i'll
give you that that was a very good one
yeah it's very good what about the um
the uh the tv show what was that called
are you talking about one division i am
you're a fan right i really liked it
another one of your co-stars yeah paul
bettany
uh i i really liked that show i thought
it was really interesting
and it and it kept me at the very edge
of my seat so is this like
this is looking at the marvel universe
through like a 1950s
sitcom is that wow you're going to enjoy
it because you haven't seen it
i haven't seen it well it goes
i don't want to give you too much no no
spoilers basically
each week 1950 sitcom next week
1960 sitcom why not telling you because
you told me not to tell you
don't tell me 70s sitcom right
the next week 1980s sitcom
i think i'm getting the trend here you
still don't want me to tell you no
well watch it okay really is it is it
worth it yeah
do you mind do you mind at this point in
the show
if i remove my shoes please have you got
socks on yeah
oh you've got those little what do you
call those socks it's like
figure-hunging
socks hey i tell you what
these guys don't like give us money or
anything
but i love bombast socks so what's the
deal with bombastics it sounds like a
spanish word well for one thing
for every pair you buy i can't believe
we're doing an ad and not getting paid
for it
for every repair you buy they give a
pair to
uh homeless shelters because that's a
good reason to advertise them anyway
straight away and then do you know what
i like about bombas they have this thing
yeah that kind of grip about it sort of
hugs your foot
and i quite like that well your wife was
the next ballet dancer right they look
like ballet dancers
socks look at that look at that
did your wife teach you that yeah she
says i've got very nice feet for a
dancer
i was devastated because i used to have
fantastic flexibility in my feet oh i
know that
in fact my left is still pretty
fantastic my right
i fractured terribly in bali
in a motorcycle accident and they had to
fuse
two toes so my big toe and what do you
call the the toe next to your big toe
middle toe
no yeah there's only pinky big toe see
the other three they don't have a name
they're nameless
really if you've got any ideas what you
might call you
you toe next to your big toe please get
in touch with this
friendship onion at castmedia.com anyway
i've had my big toe and the toe next to
my big toe
fused so they will not move now so my
my other two toes will do this
and these these toes will do that and it
looks horrible and i used to really like
my feet
yeah your feet were the first time i
ever met you you picked up a
dvd recorder with one foot i remember
you doing that and i thought that's
amazing yeah because that's quite a
weight
yeah it's sad that have you broken a
bone before just my pinky
all right on my rib
i used to do martial arts and a guy
kicked me oh yeah that's what you came
there for though isn't it
yeah you know you're asking for it
really
and i think that's all i said to a
friend the other day
the toughest thing for me in my
experience about breaking a bone and
i've broken quite a few
is you wake up in the morning and
in that moment of being awake but not
being
fully aware that you're awake yet my
brain
would send a message to that part of my
body to say are you still broken
and i would get a message back saying
yeah it was still broken
and the initial conscious thought
of kind of it's like a mini depression
and anxiety because you're like oh my
body's broke
it's such a sad way to start your day
that's my least favorite thing about
breaking the bone not the pain
not the recuperation it's the fact that
your brain says are you okay
and that part your body goes now we're
not okay yet and i go
and see all the parts of your body do
they have different voices
that's a good question or is it just a
one
it's been a while since i've broken a
bone so the next time i break a bone
i'll
i'll let you know if it hasn't you know
like is your pinky going
no we're still broken but yeah like your
thighs like
oh we'll be fine in a bit it's gonna be
a while yeah
now billy you know me there's nothing i
like more than learning new things
that's true that dawn
the spark of curiosity yes the thrill of
a new discovery
and where do we discover that spark i
tell you what we've been checking out
this place one dream right
it's brilliant i really love it i mean
they've got great
courses great things to learn hear about
great teachers i i really love it yeah
you can have fun
whilst educating yourself a couple of
weeks ago i was learning about ancient
egypt
this week it's all about bread making
because so many people have been making
bread at home
during these crazy times yeah and these
people can now pass on their tips as to
how to make the best
homemade bread i'll bring you loaf next
week that's fantastic
lately i've been looking at one of their
courses it's called
a big question of time time looking at
it
i love things like that they've got
great professors and scientists in fact
a couple of them
were saying that time is just an
illusion
fascinating trust your brain is going to
love this place
sign up now through our special url to
get this great offer
a 14 day trial a free
trial unlimited access go to
onedrive.com
onion that's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash onion wondryum.com
onion billy yes
some facts are quite fun like here's one
for you right
the first oranges weren't orange they
were green
yeah well here's something else then dom
did you know that the letter q
does not appear and any of the names of
any of the states
wow yeah and here's the last one for you
mm-hmm
turkeys can blush oh that is a good one
that's interesting right
but here's a not so fun fact americans
overspend on insurance by 21 billion
every year and you see that is where the
zebra
can help you the zebra compares car and
home insurance quotes from
every major provider in under five
minutes giving you all the facts you
need to make the right decision for you
it's the fastest way to find the right
coverage at the right price
and from a provider that you can really
trust and that
is a very fun fact so get all the facts
in one place start comparing quotes for
free
today by visiting the zebra.com slash
onion
that's the zebra.com
slash onion if you've got any
interesting stories about breaking bones
where would you send them in send us an
email at uh friendship on your cast
media.com
or you could also send us a voice
message
now that voice message can be anything
that can be
hi billion dom here's a question for you
it can be here's my story about
my life that i think you might be
interested in i'm a medical student i
know what all the tools are called
yeah so one somebody might say that
right speak
pipe dot com forward slash
the friendship onion get in touch leave
a message
subscribe to the pod the reason why you
subscribed to the party i was telling my
mom today because she didn't know about
podcast she said oh
when does it come out oh and i said it's
already out mum
and she said well what how do i how do i
listen to it where do i go to listen to
it i said go to the friendship onion
wherever you might be looking for your
other podcast and if you click subscribe
then you'd have to keep searching for it
every week it's just going to show up in
your phone maureen
she's got bigger fish to fry she's
actually frying fish today mama oh
i hope it's nice then she'll be sitting
there and she'll say what am i going to
do today
friendship onion new episode she said
say hello to you
oh please send my love to that's how you
were she's lovely
she is lovely they're a bit sad because
obviously my parents spend quite a bit
of time in spain but what with one thing
and another going on they've not been
able to get to spain for a while and
they love they love spain
my sister lives in spain yeah she does
so she loves spain i know
good for her right here we go guys
right um we've got we've had a few
messages
on our youtube channel so if you'd
rather
watch us do this podcast uh instead of
listen then you can go to the friendship
onion at youtube.com and
leave your comments there and some of
the more colorful comments right
let's give us one tom we've pulled uh
from our youtube channel
rally rayleigh rally
rally rally left us a message on our
youtube uh channel friendship onion
he said oh this is a line from the film
i go under
i feel it in the water well i feel it in
the earth
i smell it in the air that this is going
to be
my new favorite podcast
who says that i feel in the water is
that galadriel
thanks thanks riley thanks rally leave
your beautiful comments on our youtube
channel it's better to leave your
beautiful comments
underneath our podcast and raters give
us a five star review because then we'll
fly up the charts and people will get a
chance to listen to us more and more
i love it are you still hungry yeah i'm
starving guess what
what we're now at a point where we're
gonna eat the world
yes billy and dom eat the world
bill and dom eat the world what are we
eating today dom
billy's favorite part of the show today
we're gonna be eating uh
this kind of dip i guess
called jardin era it's an italian dip
that has been kind of
morphed by i think the mexican
community over here and we'll have to
find out from our
illustrious producer john if we're
having the italian version
or the mexican version but it's
basically
it's kind of like an anti-pest pasta
pesto
and tell me this dom where
in the united states would this be a
staple
food i don't know well why don't you pan
up a little bit
oh hang on we've got some information
here i would say chicago
oh chicago the windy city city of broken
shoulders
let me read this bit out for you there
you go in chicago
it's most often used on beef sandwiches
which is a chicago staple as you know
along with hot dogs
sandwiches and more recently pizza and
that's how we're having it dom are we
having it with a little pizza
it's like a dip so a lot of times we
don't really do this in britain that
much but
in the states they'll dip like ranch
yeah oh barbecue sauce buffalo buffalo
we don't do that at all dude no you get
your pizza you eat it
i'll tell you what you do in scotland
though deep fryer pizza
wow do you do that no in manchester no
no no did you try it it's crispy
when you eat a pizza if you take a slice
will you will you
fracture the slice in the middle and
fold it over sometimes i will depending
on the shape of it
oh here we go there it comes here comes
jump oh it's got the stuff already on it
remember what it's called dom jardinera
oh it does look good it looks hot by the
way do you mind if i smell it
please smell it this is um a sensory
experience for the two of us
it's pickly it smells quite pickly now
hold on
pan down a little bit dom we'll give you
some more information while we're
talking
so it's called jardiner jardiner
originally an italian
dip of sauce made with
vinegar oh lovely oh there it is
well here it is jar of it show you guys
is this a good one john is this like
oh this is the best marconi that sounds
very italian
marconi originally kind of a
vegetables in vinegar but then it was
commandeered
and became more vegetables in
oil which i think might be the one that
we're doing anyway
so the idea was it was an italian way of
preserving
vegetables from the garden you see so
and i suppose in the same way that in
korea
they would have um what's that called
kimchi kimchi would it be the same sort
of idea
suppose it's preserving it in some way
but hold on
what's good is it i know billy
well enough now to know that he'll like
that he likes a little bit of punch to
his food
now is that is that a a jalapeno there
yeah
hold on it's hard to get
oh oh god
[Laughter]
that's spicy that
[Laughter]
oh
i am i will sometimes watch the show
back
and my favorite moments of the show are
when the two of us are eating and you
can just hear us
munching into the mics because you just
sound so silly very hobbity though
don i'm having another bite you love it
don't you i absolutely love it
but you can in any way taste the pizza
it's just jardin chartenera
is that right
you're gonna have to keep talking
because i've got a little hold on
jalapeno
and my throat is hot but i like hot if
you can see me sweating it's a sweat of
joy pure joy
it's roast didn't you oh it's lovely
that no
it's a chicago style it is pickled for
longer though
right go on have you ever been to
chicago yeah i love it
windy city you pickle the vegetables
first
in chicago but then you drain it
and then you cover the vegetables with
oil
i tell you what i said they say it works
on everything there's nothing
nothing it doesn't work on now i'm not
sure how much you guys are enjoying just
listening to billy and i eat but i'm
liking this so much that i'm going to
finish the entire slice
it's excellent i can see this
on toast have you eaten a whole slice of
pizza yeah
i could have this on like sourdough
toast just like that
for because you know me i love a hot
breakfast i don't know i don't mean
heat i mean spice mm-hmm do you know
what i mean it's one of my favorite
things about southeast asia
you can wake up in the morning and you
can have a curry for breakfast and i
love that i love it
now the thing is dom a lot of people
outside of chicago
don't know about this so we are
spreading it to the
the masses what's it called again dumb
jardinera
says here sales have doubled in the last
decade
well all over the country i don't know
if you buy shares
but maybe you should buy shares in
jardin era if it's doubling
i mean that's got to be a good
investment it's irish is it no
doubling i'm sorry hold on sometimes if
i eat hot food it can make me
it can make me delirious um
this was an idea from john our producer
who i don't know if he's from chicago
maybe he is but
he loves this stuff it's a great choice
john it
now that's the best thing you've ever
done i don't
i don't know the answer to this john but
is this is jardin area available from
most supermarkets or is it a bit of an
exclusive kind of thing to get
it's a little bit harder to find out
here i bought it from
amazon oh in chicago it's everywhere so
there's a
sandwich place called pot belly that has
some of the best jardinera
um so on a sandwich it's very good
and in chicago it is all oil based but
in italy
it's vinegar-based is that right i mean
i think that they kind of traded recipes
a little bit
so now that style giaranera is more
common
um and the pickled variety is it's
almost different so if you go to
stores around here have usually the
pickled variety of giardiniera but it's
not the same
i know that one's hot but it also comes
in mild medium super hot
the hot peppers in there are what gives
it that kick i'm sweating in a good way
you're sweating too
i love it it's very very tasty sometimes
it doesn't happen as often
anymore but if i have one of those
hangovers where you think
oh this is going to be a bad day i'll
eat
a hot pickled jalapeno i know
it's combat i think chardonnaire
would be a great choice for that because
you're getting your vegetables you're
getting your heat
a couple of spoonfuls of that back to
bed come up smiling on tuesday
i'll tell you what i'm going to put a
jar in that
in my kitchen it's lovely i could i
could think of a few things that would
be good on
i'd put it in eggs oh yeah poached eggs
would be great
what'd you think of that john eggs is
very common
that's a great one eggs are coming i
have to say bill this was your idea to
do this segment on the show yeah
it's a slam dunk isn't it do you know
what i mean we're sat here chatting
and then someone brings us in food that
we've not eaten before and all we have
to do is eat it
and not only that i'm not paying for
that pizza no no
no i don't know who did castle pay for
that well it doesn't matter
guys i'll tell you what gum chardonnay
i would see everyone listening get
yourself a ton of that
and stick it in your cupboard you'll
find juices for it
so i'm going to say taste out of 10. i'm
going to give jardiner
i'm going to give it an 8.1 i'll give it
an 8.4
okay um design
of the bottle and also of the
raw materials itself because look the
bottle okay
the bottle's quite nice i have to say
it's not the most aesthetically pleasing
to look at
i'm going to give it a 4.7 out of 10.
i'll give it a 7.2 you're very positive
well i like the look if i looked at that
i would think
i would like to eat that i'd like to get
that in my gob
right and then flexibility um or
ease of use accessibility views what all
of that
that's high that's a 9.3
9.2 it's been a hit
guys it's an absolute hit if there's a
food item
that you grew up on that you love people
don't know about it
in your local area everyone raves about
it you wish more people
hate it you want us to try it we can get
hold of it
keep that in mind because if you're in a
part of the world we can't get hold of
it it's going to be difficult
but there's always a chance there might
be you know if it was
if it was a korean south korean thing
there might be a south korean
supermarket here that i'm sure john
would be able to find
and find us it and it doesn't have to be
amazing it could even be something that
you're like
we ate this and we hated it yeah we
don't understand why our mum made us eat
it
it's a strange tradition it's bizarre it
could be
food or a beverage um please
help billy and dom eat the world
yeah and just let us know what that food
is send us an email
friendship onion castmedia.com or you
can leave us a voice
mail at speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion
that was lovely john well done that was
good actually john my
face is on fire this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp
is there something that's interfering
with your happiness or maybe
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and the
great thing is dom
you can start communicating with them in
48 hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online and there is a
broad range of expertise available
which may not be locally available in
many areas the service is actually
available for clients worldwide
and you can log into your account at any
time and send a message direct to your
counselor
so visit betterhelp.com that's better
h-e-l-p
and join over a million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp
that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners get 10
of your first month at slash
betterhelp.com
hey dom summer is here at last
absolutely it is it's hot and that's
roasted
it's time to get a brand new shirt from
untuck it yeah a brand new shirt from
untuck it but why not get yourself a
performance shirt in this weather
because it wicks
the sweat off your body great idea you
don't want sweat on your body no you
don't want that
and i tell you what they've got all
sorts of different shirts untuck it
they've got short sleeve shirts which i
love lovely uh button downs
polos anything you need you'd look great
in there and
all sizes you know from small kind of
hobbit
type size all the way up to triple xl
there is a size for you
oh yeah so as we transition back into
normal things that we've been missing
like dinner with friends going out with
your family maybe a party
going for a vacation yeah get your
shirts
at untuck it use the code onion for 20
off your first purchase at untuckit.com
dom william we don't always have guests
on our show
no it's not all the time but sometimes
we get the idea of a guest or somebody
offers us a guest
that we cannot say no to yeah well hang
on a second
right have we got hillary clinton no
but we may at some point hillary get in
touch
send an email but today we
have and i'm very excited about this
yeah
we have i won't tell you what he is yet
we have
michael lopez alegria
can i guess from his name go bullfighter
no
okay although he was born in uh spain
he's got a spanish name but he
is a former nasa astronaut oh really
yes brilliant and not only that this guy
has spent more time outside
walking in space doing space walks than
any other man certainly in nasa
wow that's and you're you are mr
spaceman you're a star trek fan
a serenity fan a firefly fan you love
star wars
battlestar galactica you're the whole
thing anything with space
i'm into it i read books on space audio
books
that's all i care about while you're
talking to me right now right i'm
actually just going to start
writing down some questions for him
right you should do what will i get them
one way
hang on a second now remember this is
that's just for you not for the
astronaut this is very very serious
though
okay this is a real astronaut he's he's
in the astronaut hall of fame
really yeah how'd you get into that you
just have to be an astronaut well you
have to be one of the good ones
brilliant i'm gonna ask him about
geforce what's good for us feel like are
we good should we get him on the phone
i think we can get him on okay enough
screen hold on brilliant
let's get michael lopez alegria on the
screen
here we go hello michael can you hear us
i can you hear me all right ah wonderful
thank you so much for coming on yeah you
guys have some uh fancy microphones
there
oh yes yes we are very cutting edge no
expense spared here
michael where do we find you today
i'm uh in washington dc at home where i
live
lovely lovely well thank you very much
for coming on
we obviously have hundreds of questions
for you
when i was uh i went to drama school and
one of the first things they said to us
uh when we're trying to be actors
they said okay we're going to do a
little sort of um
acting experiment everyone choose the
job that you would
love to be from a childhood and i
of course was an astronaut i always
wanted to be an astronaut
but i had no idea as a young man from
glasgow scotland
how i'd go about that so did you
always think or want to be an astronaut
not always um i first wanted to when i
was 11 years old and and watched or
actually listened
to when a man first landed on the moon
and that lasted for a few years but then
you know i got a bit older
and in my adolescence i kind of outgrown
that
but then i much later in life when i was
a
us navy pilot who had studied
engineering and wanted to try to combine
those two things
and therefore became interested in
becoming a test pilot
i read some stuff about how a lot of the
graduates of the test pilot school the
u.s naval test pod school which is the
one that i was interested in
had gone on to become astronauts and so
the the dream was reborn so to speak
and since then i kind of put my head
down in that direction and
got very fortunate and was chosen i'll
i'm going to ask you a question here
that came up i watched
a space movie the uh the other night
there
and in fact before before i ask you this
do you have a favorite
space movie as we talk about movies on
this podcast
do you have a favorite
well i had a favorite for a very long
time uh which was apollo 13 which i
think is a fantastic movie
you know obviously quite based on fact
but then recently i saw a documentary
movie called apollo 11
which is all about the landing on the
moon and there were no actors there were
no there was no narrative it was just
uh historical footage with
newscasters telling the story and it was
brilliantly weaved together
yeah and if you know if you're a space
person um
it's it's an amazing movie i will be
watching that
cool but okay back to this one so i was
watching a space movie that i forget the
name of
someone who's still away stowaway so
it's a new one on netflix
and when they get up onto their
spaceship
they have um
like a a pretend gravity
is there any way when we're in space
that we can create a gravity yet
yeah absolutely and really all you have
to do is rotate
the spacecraft about a certain point
and the farther away you get from that
point the more and of course the faster
you're rotating the spacecraft the more
you can
uh the more acceleration you'll feel and
you know if you spin it fast enough
you'll feel
like it is on earth so there have been
lots of studies done to build a space
station
which is like that it only takes
probably a fraction
of earth's gravity to be enough to
ameliorate the effects of being in
microgravity like
muscle loss and especially bone density
loss so yeah the idea is that you would
have a
spacecraft that rotates around something
that's fixed
and when you're sleeping and living
working out not working let's say
you'd be in the exterior part
experiencing that fraction of one g
but when all the experiments are in the
middle where there's zero g
microgravity and that way you could have
the best of both worlds probably a
little bit in our future but
i think it's certainly possible so it's
a sort of
centrifugal force really rather than uh
yeah
ah so i mean how how many spins let's
say in a minute is that something that
you can
quantify at this point how
are you talking about an extraordinary
amount of spins or is it
no from what i understand it's you know
um
fractions of a revolution per minute
right at
reasonable distances would create enough
of a g field
that you would um mitigate those effects
that i described a second ago well this
is basically what that movie did
so that was good i hope you're writing
this down it's all in here it's okay
well kept in my brain
so how many times that well i'm sorry
michael
i was going to say despite the title of
the movie which makes me very skeptical
that part of it sounds pretty realistic
yeah stowaway would be like here was my
other one
and i can't just ask you a question from
this movie but there was one part
so they're at the exterior and but
they're they're doing a space walk
which i know you know all about michael
as
i if i'm writing saying you have done
more hours space walking
than anyone else is that true
anybody at nasa there's one russian
who's done more
those pesky russians that's incredible
well anyway in this movie they're at the
the end of the spinning thing
and and and they drop something and it
it goes it drops would it drop
wouldn't it just stay where you are
no if they're in the spinning part and
it's uh and they're outside
there would be subject to the same
gravity as what would be inside so yeah
it would you would go away from the
center of rotation
just uh this film is fantastic tom
i i recommend you watch it i can't get
my head around that honestly i'm a
little i'm a little lost already
michael how many times have you left
earth's
atmosphere to go to space four times
would you say that it's more
stressful on your body leaving earth's
atmosphere or coming back into it
well it depends on what vehicle you're
coming back in so on the space shuttle
we got up to three g's for a minute
leaving the atmosphere and on the way
back
it would be about a g and a half at the
most so it's not very much
but in a capsule you have about the same
g
profile going up but on the way back in
the soyuz which is the last vehicle i
flew on
we had four g's for one minute again
they're this way g
so a little bit easier to take um so
arguably the entry is harder
in in a capsule than it was um
well it is harder in a capsule than than
the ascent than the leaving the
atmosphere apart
wow and that's just a capsule that then
has a parachute at the
top of it that slows you down and
usually well the lands in the sea right
just like uh mercury gemini apollo
they're all capsules now the soyuz lands
on the earth
on the uh ground in kazakhstan um and
all the other ones as you mentioned
land in the ocean incredible i guess
they don't land
they splash down in the ocean right
and as far as um you know there's the
i suppose well known thing now of
when astronauts see the world from the
outside that
changes their whole thoughts about
everything have was there any feeling of
that when you
went to space just feeling of how small
you are or how small the earth is even
yeah certainly i mean you said it well
when we
you know you go around the earth uh
every 90 minutes and as you do that the
earth is turning
underneath us and so you're seeing a
different swath of earth as you go by
and that really gives you some
perspective and
you know you begin to realize that uh
all of us
on this planet are essentially crewmates
on the same spaceship
and it's the only spaceship that looks
at all interesting out there
you know the other ones don't seem it
seems very inhospitable when you look
away from earth and very
welcoming when you look to her so you
definitely
have a feeling of connectivity you know
both to the other inhabitants of the
planet and to the planet itself
makes you want to really think about
taking care of it
what do you say to those crazy yahoo
people
who us who suspect that the
moon landings were faked if if someone's
if you're sat next to someone in a bar
unfortunately and someone's giggling on
about the moon landings were faked
how what would be the comment that you
would hope would
destroy their argument
uh i'd probably buy them a drink it's a
good start
and then you know i have
no my feeling is i have no explanation
that would move the needle for them
so i would probably just say you know
we'll have to agree to disagree
and move on it's it's a lost argument
for me it's
it's not if somebody thinks that i just
don't know how to change their mind
right right where do you where do you
think it will be
in 50 years do you think 55-0
yeah well hard to tell
i mean i think i'm quite confident that
there will be a vibrant economy in
earth orbit and we'll have multiple
space stations probably some
manufacturing facilities that might even
be
unmanned because honestly humans kind of
disrupt the perfect microgravity that
you can get otherwise
and some of the manufacturing processes
are really sensitive to that kind of
microgravity environment so i i would
expect
we'll have you know relatively routine
transportation if you look back at
commercial aviation
you know almost 100 years ago only very
very wealthy people could
could fly and now people go on an
airplane to drop off a bucket
right yeah yeah however and it's
similarly
huge private human spaceflight right now
is extraordinarily expensive
unfortunately but over time and maybe in
50 years it'll be to the point where
it's not like um you know spending your
life's fortune and
yeah probably those of everybody you
know
yeah but rather something that is
affordable but billy can afford it he
was in load the rings right
he's made of money seriously mercedes
insult you michael but go on
um now that'd be great we have to ask
michael
there life anywhere else in the universe
well i have to think that there is i
mean the universe is just too big to
think otherwise
okay and your next question is when are
we going to meet them
i think that because of that very same
vastness
it's probably not going to happen at
least you know in our
in our collective experiences humanity i
mean the distances are so incredible
that we think about you know our moon
which is 250 000 miles away
mars is you know almost a thousand times
that
so it's um it's a pretty
heavy slog to think of going outside our
solar system outside our galaxy
to one of the other 100 billion galaxies
that are out there
i just have to ask you as a quick fire
questions then
as someone who knows but open your mind
up here
when will we have a man on mars
when will that happen wait wait what
matt
matt daniel no that was exactly four
years ago that was a movie
oh go on sorry michael sorry michael
that was a movie that's confusing
uh i personally think that won't happen
in my lifetime um i think it's just a
tough
tough thing you know think about how far
it is yeah
with today's propulsion it would take
you know six to nine months to get there
six to nine months to get back okay and
then because of the way the
planetary mechanics work out you have to
spend about six months there
so you're looking at a two-year mission
you have to bring all the food
all the water all the clothing all the
oxygen
all the fuel i mean that's a gigantic
logistics
so you could try to pre-position it
there but it would be
massively expensive and i think without
some
preponderant forcing function
geopolitical which is what got us to the
moon
is hard to imagine economic is even
harder to imagine since we know
relatively little about it so i don't
see it happening in my lifetime i hope
i'm wrong yeah is it not frustrating for
you michael and everyone that you work
with
that the mars rover
battery has been running for years but
we have to charge our phone every night
do you know what i mean like they have
the technology
your phone would probably be a lot more
expensive if you had that kind of
battery
they're already expensive thousand
dollars for too much
do you have a favorite planet michael
earth
mine is saturn what's the one
like the rings yeah what's the one that
reigns
diamonds is that jupiter
never heard that but oh i heard this one
on the planet it might it might be
i think i think there's a chance
somewhere in the universe but i don't
think in our solar system
you might be wrong i'll google that
later um
wow it's like the more questions that we
ask the more
questions i have oh i know i was going
to ask you michael apart from a loss of
bone density
and a potential loss of
muscle density if you if you're not
working out in in the way that you hope
to in space
are there any other things that you're
more susceptible to sickness-wise or
illness-wise in space
well we definitely get more radiation
than we do on earth and um
and so you know cancer is a bigger
risk however the numbers uh show that
within the astronaut population compared
to the general population it there's not
a significant difference
the the wrinkle though is that the
astronaut population is generally pretty
darn healthy right that's
part of the selection process so maybe
if you
if you selected a group of ground test
subjects who were exposed to less
radiation maybe there would be a
difference
the other thing that we're having a hard
time figuring out and this is just
uh associated with long duration space
flight by that i mean more than
say 30 days or so is we have some we see
some ocular
problems uh mostly in older males but
also you know throughout the astronaut
population
and so i for example lost some um
i became a little bit more farsighted
when i was in space you know how
as we get older arms get too short right
you can't can't get far enough away from
what you're reading
so that happened to me but at a rather
accelerated pace
for the seven months during my last
mission and
come back with other um eye related
issues that generally go away but the
vision changes do not and of course
that's not the end of the world but
it's uh it's something that we're still
trying to sort out the cause of
like you said it tends to happen to
everyone as they age but with astronauts
it seems to be slightly accelerated with
with
with male astronauts exactly interesting
and what's the longest you've spent in
space
seven months i flew three
roughly two week missions and then seven
months arduous on the
on the physical body that's a space walk
you know we train for space walks in a
in a giant swimming pool um in almost
exact same suits which is weighed out to
be
neutrally buoyant so that simulates the
zero gravity
and it's pretty good simulator for that
but
training in that is actually a little
bit more work because you have the
viscosity of the water to deal with
whereas outside obviously it's a vacuum
so it's a little bit easier
but i would say sort of mentally and
emotionally the actual spacewalk is is
much tougher because
obviously you're in space going you know
17 000 miles an hour
250 miles above the surface of the earth
and while that's a spectacular view it
can be a bit unnerving
there must be moments right if you're
honest
when you're out there if you're out
there for six hours and you're doing
something
that do you ever get a wave of fear
of i'm standing on the edge of like
nothing i think that happens to people
right when they go outside the airlocks
right the very first thing and you get
over it
you know quite quickly then what happens
to you though
is you see this beautiful view and i
mean the view from the iss
is spectacular you just can't compare it
to anything but when you're outside the
iss
that is like nothing you could even
conceive it you know you're looking
through a visor so you have an
almost perfect unobstructed view
and um it's you know you really get the
sense of
you know a moving fast b how
beautiful this planet is and you really
want to stop what you're doing and
you know just take in the view but of
course we can't do that for very long
and i take it you only get the feeling
of speed when you look at the earth
you don't feel speed right
correct you don't feel anything and if
you're just looking at the space station
up close you don't notice it and if you
let go with both hands which is
inadvisable
you know technically is if you don't
push off or anything you won't go
anywhere you'll just fly
yeah you know in formation if you will
we always have a tether
so you can let go with two hands but
it's uh it's discouraged
that was i was gonna ask that was
another one from that movie i watched
last night
at one point they're out walking on this
spaceship and they weren't
tethered that would never happen right
yeah that would never happen unless they
had some sort of a manual
uh or automated you know backpack
device to they could fly around in so we
used to have that actually and
in the shuttle days yeah they would
actually put this thing on and go
retrieve wayward satellites
we don't have that anymore that was a
very expensive
very sophisticated multiple redundancy
kind of system
we do have a little backpack now though
which we use only for rescue so
if you happen to let go with both hands
and your tether gets
either dis unattached or breaks
which is pretty unlikely we can deploy
this mechanism a hand controller
basically and orient ourselves and fly
back
to the space station so i actually got
to test it once on purpose
wow and and it was quite a thrill
yeah like gravity that happens a lot in
that film gravity right it's a lot of
like being untethered
oh you don't want that so michael if
you're
doing a space walk you're working away
at something not looking at the planet
but you've glanced at
it then you do your job and you look
back at the planet let's say
half an hour later are you seeing a
completely different view of planet
earth at that point
100 in fact every 45 minutes
it gets you either it gets dark or it
gets light so you see a sunrise or
sunset every 45 minutes
that's amazing you're going from being
between the
sun and the earth to being behind the
earth's shadow
and um so yeah it in 15 minutes you
would or you said 30 minutes you would
certainly
go you go from the pacific ocean to the
atlantic ocean
um and you would never see the us
incredible
and what about sleeping up there does
that make that difficult
it can be hard i mean most people have
no trouble falling asleep because you're
actually
pretty tired at the end of the day um
again a lot of it is sort of mental and
emotional
much more than physical but what's hard
is is staying asleep
you know when you're lying in bed here
on earth and you have that
gratifying sensation of having your head
on a pillow
that doesn't exist unless you velcroed a
pillow to your head
and some people do that so you we
we basically sleep in sleeping bags that
are zipped up
to keep us from floating around and the
sleeping bags can be
on the floor but more often they're on
the walls or even on the ceiling and uh
what's missing is that sort of sense of
lying down which yeah so i really
appreciate it once i got back
mike i have one last question buzz
aldrin
or buzz lightyear
they're two different things as far as i
know yeah
oh this is uh i don't know buzz
lightyear at all
you've never been exposed to the to the
magic of toy story
there's a movie you should watch i
so is that a is that a space movie
should we put that it's a story about
kids toys that wake up and one of the
guys is called buzz lightyear and he's
kind of an inept
space adventurer astronaut he's really
sweet his heart's in the right place
you'd like him he means well well then
let's give him
a chance at least right there we go
thanks michael
when did when did you do your 10 day
next
next mission sometime in january or
february that's a plan we don't have a
launch date yet but it'll be in the
first
month or two wow well if you can never
get me up there please let me know
i don't even mind not coming back
i know michael nowadays it's quite
popular for them to televise
launches will your launch be something
that we can watch online
yeah i'm assuming so this is just a
private
mission so it won't be on nasa tv
although we are going to the
international space station so there
might be some coverage of us while we're
on board
but i'm sure that uh axiom and spacex
who is our launch provider
will be interested in publicizing it
will be there you never know
i can't wait i'll come over to yours and
we'll do like a popcorn
i would love it i love it a real space
movie
this has been fascinating michael um so
brilliant to talk to you and wish you so
much
luck and safety on your next mission
thanks guys it was a pleasure for me too
all the best thank you
thank you very much michael bye bye bye
dom i am exhausted
i love that it was brilliant but i am
physically and mentally
spent just trying to imagine
what michael's gone through did you feel
as if you've just had a six hour space
walk
yeah it's brilliant can you believe he's
never seen toy story
that he told us the most fascinating
fact for me is that he doesn't know who
buzz lightyear is maybe he just didn't
have
he's never had time to watch it
brilliant brilliant questions from you
but that's not going to be our last
guest oh
no no in fact if there's anyone out
there with an amazing job
or something that they want to tell us
some something that they're obsessed by
something that they're interested
in get in touch with us we want to hear
from you we're all about learning new
skills right yeah if there's any guests
that you'd like to see on the show
please let us know we'll get them on
here
billy's got a very sore knee if there's
anyone out there that knows how to fix
knees get in touch see
people wanted to get in touch with us
with an idea
of a guest i mean i got my guest i got
an astronaut maybe someone does a
fascinating job that they want to tell
us about maybe we're curious about it
exactly maybe they want to be a guest
how would they get in touch with us at
the friendship onion well a good way to
get in touch with us obviously
friendship onion
casts media.com or they can leave a
voicemail how do they do that
well they go to speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion get
in touch if you want to be part of the
show we'd love
to hear from you rate review subscribe
subscribe
but only if you like it if you don't
like it stay away
see you friends all the best